sadiq load French Montana praises his
ex-girlfriend Khloe Kardashian
during the NBA Finals Khloe Kardashian
was getting a lot of heat how did she
handle that did you ever call her up and
just give her some support and some love
and just be like don't sweat what all
these people are saying she used to
pressure I mean she's she's she's
definitely a dope dope lady you know did
she's used to pressure I don't think
like I don't it for me from what I know
about don't think about though she go
right through it like a champ really oh
yeah yeah definitely
I mean people I mean people always say
gonna say stuff about you know body wash
you know she know how to handle it the
rapper opened up to et on the red carpet
at the BT Awards before taking the stage
with sway Lee
[Music]
I flew all the kids in Africa here from
Uganda took him to Universal yesterday
it was the first time ever in the museum
part it was like you know it just warm
my heart to do nothing to take him from
from Uganda dancing you know like that
like like I want to flow in the mud and
everything to 100 million people
watching and or are they handling being
here oh my god they losing it it's a
dream for some attic of a maverick I I
got a chance to experience it coming
from Morocco so you know it's kind of
you know it's kind of a dream for me to
you know
[Music]
you